fire hydrants without water Saturday
afternoon a huge plume of black smoke
hovered over the Central Valley and that
was due to a fire at an abandoned Kmart
on Sahara near McLeod it took extra time
to put it out because the fire hydrants
around it had no water Ryan Matthey live
from the aftermath now where that water
was Ryan
yeah Brian Denise the color of fire
hydrants it actually means something
it's important to the fire that was
right behind me here think this red
means public or excuse me yellow means
publicly maintained red means privately
maintained we counted six red ones in
around the building that's right behind
me here they're the same fire hydrants
that fire officials say they could not
get water from when that fire was
happening on Saturday and now the people
who lived nearby and work nearby are
fearful for the next fire and if there
will be water to put it out
a three-alarm blaze taking nearly 80
firefighters to put out not sure why
there were some um we call them like
dead hydrants that night Clark County
Deputy fire chief Billy Samuels said
Crews were forced to venture outside the
property to find any water prolonging
response to an emergency that nearly
burnt the building to the ground they
had to block everybody off run a daisy
chain of hoses from this fire hydrant
all the way down to the road Michael
Barbosa lives behind the property these
photos show The Towering smoke plume
next door and the fire hoses snaking
through his neighborhood the fire was
close enough to if it blown back this
way it could have sparked back to one of
the houses because when I first walked
out I thought maybe possibly one of
these apartments were on fire and we're
gonna do then maybe value everything
like 40 50k that's how much inventory
Drew Shaw says was inside his screen
printing company that was also just a
wall away from the flames and if uh help
Emergency Services come around to try to
put it out it might be delayed the
damage gets worse I mean it's a recipe
for disaster in unincorporated Clark
County if it's yellow the Las Vegas
Valley Water District maintains it the
hydrants around the building red meaning
the property owner maintains it a
spokesperson tells 8 news now that the
property manager requested water be
turned off in May 2022 for repairs but
that call to turn it back on was never
requested
now that spokesperson says that in the
entire unincorporated County they
maintain a small team 37 000 fire
hydrants that does not include the tens
of thousands of red and privately owned
fire hydrants in the county the yellow
ones those are maintained at least once
a year the red ones that is up to the
property owner reporting live near
Sahara and McLeod rymathy a news now